démonstration de force contre
démonstration de force ce dimanche les
biélorusses étaient de sortie dans les
rues de minsk pour combattre ou soutenir
c'est selon alexandre lukashenko
plusieurs milliers de partisans du
président fraîchement réélu se sont
rassemblés place de l'indépendance face
au palais de la république siège du
gouvernement biélorusse brandissant les
couleurs officielles du pays
c'est probook à celle qu ont défendu le
bilan de leur président je suis ici
parce que la biélorussie est stable
depuis 26 ans nous n'avons pas ce mal
vécu nous avons sorti le pays de la
ruine
nous avons tous restaurés les usines
fonctionnent tout fonctionne il suffit
d'aller travailler
je veux que les enseignants et les
autres fonctionnaires reçoivent leurs
salaires
que les pensions soient payés compagnie
considère que les actions des autorités
sont adaptés alexandre loukachenko a
d'ailleurs fait une apparition au cours
de cette manifestation et prononcé un
discours exhortant ses concitoyens à
défendre l'indépendance de la
biélorussie certains veulent de
nouvelles élections
regarder par la fenêtre il ya des chars
et des avions à 15 minutes de nos
frontières
ce n'est pas un hasard
les forces de l'otan déployées
quipements à nos portes les forces
militaires se massent aux frontières
occidentales de notre pays mais les
quelques milliers de soutiens aux chefs
d'état auront fait pâle figure face à
l'immense foule rassemblée à seulement
deux kilomètres de là près d'une
centaine de milliers de personnes
réunies autour du musée de l'histoire de
la grande guerre nationale de
biélorussie soit le plus grand
rassemblement d'opposants de l'histoire
du pays
cette fois les drapeaux sont blancs et
rouges couleur de l'éphémère république
populaire biélorusse qui vécut moins
d'une année
entre mars 1918 et janvier 1919 un
symbole d'indépendance pour ces
manifestants qui refusent
catégoriquement le sixième mandat
d'alexandre loukachenko
j'ai fait mon choix et mon vote a été
jeté à la poubelle donc je continuerai à
sortir manifester jusqu'à ce que notre
président parte il est déjà fatigué et
il est temps d'avoir un changement de
pouvoir regarder et vous verrez combien
de personnes sont ici et vous
comprendrez que le président n'a pas
obtenu 80 % des voix tout le monde
comprend que notre présidente
sv cana tiralos callas et que nous
sommes ici pour la soutenir pour qu'il y
est enfin des changements dans notre
pays ce fait la nature anoska ya soit la
principale opposante à loukachenko lors
du dernier scrutin
exilé en lituanie à la suite de
probables pressions
elle a lancé vendredi un appel pour
l'organisation de rassemblements
pacifiques
ses partisans ont répondu présent à
minsk et mais aussi à travers toute la
biélorussie comme ici à brest dans le
sud ouest du pays un appel à la grève
nationale circulaient également sur les
réseaux sociaux la contestation
biélorusse semble n'en être qu'à ses
débuts